after mamma mia two did cher  get the mamma mia tattoo that the rest  of you got  no no this ages ago this was mamma mia  one  oh okay she bought me a two and mamia  won  my my girlfriends ashley and rachel  one of them is liverpudlian and the  other one is scottish  and they we just minge was a thing minge  became  beautiful i mean i'm mingy on instagram  like minge do you know how many texts i  got for my birthday today that say happy  birthday minge like that's what my  friends taught me  and that's called each other and so  therefore  minge and we got that tattoo god years  ago oh my god years ago  and people made fun of me for it i can't  remember  what it's not i'm not talking about a  vagina anymore it's a it's a term of  endearment  i understand vaginas but it's not  a vagina on my foot it's my name yeah  [Music]